معنى من بونالو سد جاسم محمد الخبير في
الامن الدولي ومدير مركز مكافحه الارهاب
والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه استاذ جاسم اهلا وسهلا بك
عقب حادث في بولندا كانت هناك دعوات
للتحفظ لكن الرئيس الامريكي دفع ببعض
المؤشرات تقول لنا الصاروخ اوكرانيه ما
تداعيات هذا الحادث حادث صواريخ في بولندا
الصاروخ هو مصدر روسي بدون شكوى سوف يكون
له عواقب وخيمه على الامن الدولي وهنا
نتحدث عن تفعيل الماده اربعه داخل نيته
وهي اصلا مفعله الان من خلال الاجتماع
بروكسيل ان توفي بروكسل وكذلك قمه العشرين
وكذلك تشاور والاتصالات مباشره داخل
الفنيته هذه جميعا هي تقول بان الماده
اربعه هي مفعله الماده خمسه فهي الخطوه ما
بعد الماده اربعه فاذا اجد انه همم يعني
همم منتدياتها زياده التوتر في الامن
الدولي واجد انه العالم في الوقت الحاضر
لم يشهد التوتر منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه لحد الان مثل ما يشهد له الان
واجد انه الان اا يعني نتائج ايجابيه خاصه
التصريحات وتعليقات ال20
خليك كامل الناتو انها لا مؤشر ان الصاروخ
ومصدره روسي وهذا تكون ربما اشاره ايجابيه
في التهدئه
جسم تحدث عن هذا التوتر غير المسبوق بعد
حديث بولندا الى اي ماده ربما قد يدفع ذلك
الى الدعوه مجددا الى مفاوضات سلام بين
روسيا واوكرانيا وشاهدنا ذلك اخيرا قمه
مجموعه ال20
هنالكم ايجابيه انسحاب روسيا من همم جزء
من خيرسون الى الجهه الاخرى من اضافه
النار النار وكذلك انه لاحظ انه التصريحات
التي ادلى بها بايتن بانه لها مؤشر بان
اثاره روسي وممكن ان يكون انطلق من داخل
الاوكرانيا ما عدا ذلك هنالك اذا تصريحات
همم منزل
بان ممكن ان تكون هنالك او ممكن ان يتم
استعاده المشاورات وهنا همم يذكر بان
الدوره الفرنسي الدوري الالماني وكذلك دور
تركيا اجدد انه ممكن ان يكون فاعل ومؤثر
اجت انه الان برقم محادثه هذه انه الوضع
الان ربما هو افضل وضع تشهده اوكرانيا ما
بين روسيا وكذلك اوكرانيا
الى جانب الموقف الالماني والفرنسي في هذه
الموقف الفرنسي كان داعما لي موقف ووسطه
اكبر للصين ما الدور الذي يمكن ان تطلع به
يعني الصين في هذا الملف وهل يمكن ان تلعب
فعلا هذا الدور
الصين تحاول ان تحافظ على علاقتها مع
روسيا ولكن هي ايضا هي لا تشجع روسيا بان
تكون هنالك يعني استمرار في الحرب ايضا
تطالب بواقف هذا الحرب وفي نفس الوقت
نلاحظ انه الصين ايضا تحاول ان توازن في
علاقاتها مع اوروبا خاصه الان دخلت السوق
الاوروبيه ولو تحدثنا عن المانيا
واستثمارات ايضا فيها همبرج فاذا اجد انه
الصين تدفع في اتجاه التهدئه لكن اجد انه
لا يكون لها تاثير كبير على ايقاف الحرب
في اوكرانينيا
في الامن الدولي ومدير مركز مكافحه
الارهاب والدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا لك